und jetzt ich weiß Sie haben darauf
gewartet live aus dem Bundestag in
Berlin
super Spannung das Power Quiz und hier
kommen unsere Kandidaten Andreas
Konstanz ich bin Sprecher für Energie-
und Klimaschutz der inselspraktion und
ebenfalls herzlich willkommen moin moin
ich bin Ingrid Nestle Sprecherin für
Energie und Klima der grünen
Bundestagsfraktion und was wäre das Quiz
ohne sie nachher Klimaschutz und
energiepolitische Sprecherin der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion für die Witze
zuständig der von der FDP wir schaffen
das mit der Energiewende und der Meinung
ist und wie immer mit dabei Karl
Lauterbach eine Frage
herzlich Willkommen zu super Spannung
das Power Quiz sind Sie bereit ich bin
bereit dann starten wir jetzt mit der
ersten Frage wie viele Windräder werden
für den Braunkohletagebau Garzweiler
weggebaggert a natürlich keins da wir
gerade heute jedes Windrad brauchen oder
B
acht gehen weg wahrscheinlich und wir
legen das nachher mit Sonnenkollektoren
aus und gewinnen dann Vielfaches aber
erstmal sind jetzt ja acht Windräder Weg
wir wollen uns gerne auch persönlich
verabschieden von den acht Windrädern
gleich einmal tschüss
das ist eine Investition ich
verabschiede mich auch macht's gut
wir haben schon 30 % mehr Windräder
gebaut dieses Jahr als im Jahr davor bis
Oktober war auch nicht so schwer weil
letztes Jahr war ja das schlechteste ja
aller Zeiten
kriegen
Windrad baut dann ist das ja auch schon
mehr das war mehr als eins
was bezeichnet man als die sogenannte
Peter altmaierdelle a die 60.000
verlorenen Jobs in der Windbranche dank
Peter Altmaier B die 100.000 verlorenen
Jobs in der Solarbranche dank Peter
Altmaier oder C beides
ich finde man macht sich so einfach wenn
man gar noch personalisiert oder C
beides beides
entscheidend ist es jetzt gelingt die
Energiewende zu beschleunigen wir müssen
Technologien nutzen wir müssen die
Vorgänge beschleunigen aber warum haben
sie das nicht schon die letzten 16 Jahre
gemacht
wie müsste man ein Windrad nennen damit
es schnell und zügig in Deutschland
gebaut wird
Autobahn oder B Tagebau Christian
Lindner
es liefert die ganze Zeit Strom es macht
warum es macht sogar es macht sogar
selber Wind es macht selber richtig Wind
jetzt macht's natürlich verstanden
wenn ich als Bürger eine erfolgreiche
Energiewende erleben möchte was muss ich
dann tun a noch ein bisschen abwarten
die Ampel schafft das schon oder B
auswandern wir arbeiten schon unter
Hochdruck an allen möglichen
Schalthebeln ist zu vereinfachen ist zu
ermöglichen die Energiewende zu
beschleunigen aber jeder kann ja auch
noch seinen weiteren eigenen Beitrag
leisten und deswegen würde ich
rausnehmen
gewesen
jedem Bürger in Deutschland berät
erfolgreiche Energiewende
packen ich weiß nicht was sie tun
ich gehe jetzt irgendwo hin wo die
Energiewende funktioniert ich bedanke
mich
und das ist ihr promijoker
darum stellt ihr wir stellen jetzt mal
eine Frage und wenn Sie nicht weiter
wissen
wir aber das ist ja das Gute
2004 wurden 7500 km an großen
Stromtrassen geplant um die Energiewende
zu schaffen wie viele Kilometer sind 18
Jahre später gebaut a die Antwort ist so
schlimm ich halt mir lieber die Ohren zu
oder B also dann müssen sich jetzt die
Ohren weil jetzt kommt die richtige
Antwort
nicht mal ein Zehntel seit 2004 haben
sie gesagt
also ich würde sagen das ist ein
bisschen mehr als ein Zehntel
nehmen Sie den promijoker
ein Unternehmen möchte in ganz
Deutschland Wind und Solaranlagen bauen
und sieht sich unter anderem mit 16
verschiedenen
Landesbauordnungen konfrontiert wann
kann das Unternehmen
ich sehe gerade die Frage übt sich das
Unternehmen ist ins Ausland abgewandert
sind wir raus
nee es hat sich übrig
weiß ja nicht wie der Satz zu Ende geht
ja das Unternehmen kann am Anfang des
Jahres wesentlich schneller auch
Baugenehmigung bekommen deswegen haben
wir ja das EG reformiert und deswegen
ist es auch für ausländische Unternehmen
übrigens möglich in Deutschland wenn
Energieanlagen zu bauen Photovoltaik
selbstverständlich auch da machen sie
doch jetzt mal Werbung Liebe Unternehmen
in der ganzen Welt wir freuen uns wenn
ihr nach Deutschland kommt um den Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren zu beschleunigen made
in Germany gilt auch für die
Erneuerbaren wir laden eure Unternehmen
herzlich ein hier zum Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren beizutragen wir haben die
längsten Genehmigungsverfahren der Welt
nein das war ja der Werbeblock sie
wollen 16 verschiedene Landesbauordnung
wie geil ist das denn Deutschland
alles auf Papier gedruckt
welches science-fiction-projekt wird
zuerst realisiert a ein bemannter Flug
zum Mars B das Christian Lindner die
Schuldenbremse aufweicht oder C eine
einheitliche Online-Anmeldung für
Anlagenbetreiber bei den über 900
deutschen Netzgesellschaften in die Zeit
läuft jetzt abläuft 10 Sekunden jetzt
natürlich kann das alles geschafft
werden und die Schuldenbremse ich
denke gerade die ganze Zeit darüber nach
ob Sie Ihre Fragen
passiert wir dürfen es nicht sagen
nein nein nein also wenn es nicht
öffentlich wird aber
das ist richtig und damit haben sie
gewonnen Lauterbach und zwar diesen
Aktenordner und dazu noch leer kriegen
sie 500 Seiten Papier das reicht für
einen Antrag für ein halbes Windrad ist
das nicht toll ja vielen Dank
herzlichen Glückwunsch
[Musik]
Fabian Lutz ich bin hier hier folgt
meiner Stimme ah ich habe dich jetzt
übertreiben die das aber mit dem
Energiesparen oder sogar in der endcard
ja klickt HIER wenn ihr abonnieren wollt
oder hier für weitere Videos
wo geht's denn jetzt hier raus ich
glaube da lang ah mein Fuß